- Someone has to water the plants.
Water the plants.
- So, a year ago, when I was an intern,
my old boss Cody was religious
about us watering the plants.
- He's very organized, always
prepared for every job,
and just constantly on top of everything.
- I created an Excel spreadsheet.
He would come in on weekends
and water the plants himself,
and actually put his name
on the Excel spreadsheet.
- If we didn't water the plants,
he would, like, message us individually,
being like, hey did you water the plants?
I definitely feared my job a few times.
- Now that I'm no longer an intern,
it's time to get him back.
So, we bought the exact same dead plants,
and swapped them out with the live ones.
The intern Ricky has taken
over watering the plants
for the last two months,
and he has no idea what's about to happen.
We set up hidden cameras
pretending to film other videos,
and mic'd up all the desks.
I've been dreaming about
pulling this prank on Cody
for the past six months.
So, we just swapped out the
live plants for the dead ones,
and we got Laina, head
of the art department,
to go in, and let Cody know,
that his plants are dying.
- I was looking at these guys out here,
and they kind of,
they look like they haven't
been watered in awhile,
so I was just like, let me check with you.
- According to the log here,
Ricky's watering the plants.
Ricky.
Plants, man.
Have they not been watered?
- I mean, they look pretty, pretty bad.
I don't know.
- I just watered them this morning, dude.
- They were green, and now they're all,
all the plants are brown.
Like the whole plant is brown.
- Well, when did you water them last?
- This morning!
- As per the little schedule
we got Ricky the past three days.
(all clamoring)
- Look here, look.
- So, Ricky just walked outside,
and is looking at the alive plants,
and is super confused at what is going on.
- Find him?
- Our plants?
- They're dead?
- What?
- I don't understand.
- What plants are outside right now?
Where are the three of
ours that have been alive?
(all talking)
Where are the dead ones?
The dead ones are gone.
- [Voiceover] Something
weird is happening.
- There are three
healthy plants out there.
And the three that we saw two minutes ago
are somewhere else.
- Okay, Cody does not
appear to be coming outside
a third time to see the dead plants.
So, we just sent Andrew,
the head of the department,
to go up to him and say something.
- Hey, dude, have you seen the plants?
These are totally brown.
- Cody, your interns are asleep.
- I don't even know what's
happening right now.
- Alright, time to go tell him.
(all laughing and talking)
- Is all this gear for this right now?
- [Voiceover] So, this is all a joke.
- This has all been a joke.
(laughter)
- So, I'm super happy with
the way the prank turned out.
Ironically, I think this ended up
being more of a prank on Ricky.
- Thought my head was gonna explode.
They kept on flipping, it was insane.
My brain really has like a flip in it.
I was like, I need to see a neurologist.
- But, I still pranked Cody.
That was my goal in the end.
- Very elaborate.
But, nice work.
You guys pulled it off.
- [Voiceover] Why do you feel
like they need to stay alive?
(laughter)
- Can't believe this.
Monsters, that I work with.